[Music]
what's your name
Janko then you're exactly the word I'm
looking for does the movie ever explain
how you heard about Django in the first
place like who's the guy that told him
the story about Django this one slave
from four states away who one time
worked with these white dudes but then
got sold and is now in Texas yeah go see
him he'll be able to lead you to the
criminals you're looking for also he
managed to find Django without knowing
what he looked like I mean how hard
could it be to find three slave driving
brothers in Gatlinburg without knowing
what they look like and a world full of
random cameos this is one of the most
random there's very little foam on this
glass but then both glasses have tons of
foam and Django has had a couple of
drinks here but then his glass is full
again in the next shot and Schultz's
glass is 1/3 empty here but then
magically gets more full the Sun is
clearly over the Marshalls right
shoulder and he's facing the saloon door
but when we see his point of view we see
his shadow as if the Sun was over his
left shoulder should the shadow be over
here is she talking to
Django is a fan of Austin Powers a full
140 years before its release
why does janko's memories of this
incident looked like someone filmed a TV
that was playing a 70s movie Lords it's
not truly a Tarantino movie until
someone starts quoting scripture
brilliant and visionary director relies
on stupid movie trope of the bad guy
fumbling his gun okay so the way
Tarantino shoots this perspective wise
the guy hightailing across the field is
going left to right but then when
Schultz him he's shot from the front but
Schultz even track from left to right as
the guy was writing so how in the name
of the magic bullet did he pull this
shot off there's easily more than 30
guys in this racist posse movie explains
away the fact that the slave is a crack
shot by saying it's just in his DNA
the kids a natural slave auction town in
Mississippi isn't the place for him to
visit free or not it's just too
dangerous when the snow melts I'll take
you to Greenville myself why doesn't he
just take Django to Greenville himself
right now if he's a natural why does he
need to have a practice montage Django's
attempt to pretend like he's not going
to grab this guy is terrible but the
idiot on the horse still falls for it
does nothing the source goes down with
the rider but then is instantly upright
in the next shot how does anyone buy
this excuse for a conversation between
Django and Schultz what are they
supposed to least try
anything about which fighter they
haven't yet seen that they're gonna buy
I understand Schultz's reluctance to
shake Candy's hand even on principle but
he not only in dangers the deal but in
dangers both Django and broomhilda's
lives by being stubborn over a handshake
apparently no one hears this gunshot
candy Falls against the bookcase and it
takes Candy's man book more than 20
seconds to react Schultz decides to
apologize to Django when he should be
blasting the unobservant boiler room why
is this guy turn to the side aiming at
the front door
apparently unconcerned by the
bloodthirsty Django coming right at it
Oh for convenience I guess because the
front doors where Django's aiming next
and now he can use this dude as a human
shield this dead guy's totally breathing
Jamie Foxx's balls
Django only gets to keep his nuts
because of the most convenient timing
ever Quentin Tarantino's acting an
accent did the Candyland people find the
handbills in Django saddlebag but not
the ones in his fucking pants pockets
you'd like to make Levin thousand
dollars I know money talks but these
Australian slave drivers never buy into
this total bull about an eleven thousand
dollar fortune the whole reason for the
scene is so that the awful things that
Django did in this movie finally pay off
when the slaves bound for his store in
Warren mostly so the dude toss that
dynamite into the cage and then what
forgot to close and lock it was this
thing open the whole time why didn't the
explosion scare these horses into
running away like the other ones why
would anyone sit at this angle with this
particular view boy Django sure is angry
about darkanian's death for which he is
basically single-handedly responsible
boy it sure is lucky that everyone's off
at the funeral while Django sets up the
death trap at Candyland
Django blows his cover slowly walks to
the balcony and lights a candle in his
gun hand and isn't blown away
immediately
why didn't miss Laura just run for
another room in the shooting star the
whole reason for Django even being here
broom-hilda sits out in plain view in
front of the house instead of hiding in
case something goes wrong
I know Django is cool and everything but
this blast would definitely have blown
him back or at least hit him with some
debris at this range
Tarantino couldn't resist putting one
more n-word in the end credits scene
[Music]
perfect shiny white teeth on slave
traders beer taps my violin French
pronunciation of valid in a party bus to
pop off beer caps straws cigarette
holders
yummo booze the freeze mother for
release dynamite booze
[Music]
Hoppa got 10 more days be in there how
many niggas you think you see come and
go huh 7,000 8,000 9,000 the number of
slaves Stephen has seen come and goes
definitely over 9000